so my oldest daughter
home from college and she
approached me because i guess i'm an old
person and i don't understand what's
happening in the world
and maybe the videos that we make echo
charles and myself
maybe they're a little bit out of date
in terms of
the way they come across so have an open
mind about this
i want to help understand her
perspective i said okay cool
what idea do you have well it turns out
not even her idea which is fine
uh 10 things that you
can't live without which already were
done
because there is not 10 things that i
can't live without it would have to be
10 things that you utilize on a regular
basis
how's that
my daughter selected some things that i
seem to have
some sort of
well some sort of sentimental attachment
to
okay so yeah so so this right here good
good i'm glad that you you selected this
this is a chalk bag
for working out these are wristbands
that keep the sweat
off of my hands and this is a little
notebook this is sort of my this is my
travel go bag for working out
and as long as you can find some kind of
pull-up bar you're good forever
i use this i use i'm i i am
a big utilizer of chalk when i go to
gyms
and there's a chalk not a loud sign
so i i do play the guitar i'm not very
good i'm trying to get better
when i got kovid and i wasn't allowed to
go anywhere i started learning all the
notes on the fretboard which i'd never
done before
so yeah i play guitar and i actually
have a bunch of guitars
do i prefer acoustic or electric
let's face it with an electric guitar
you can bring the thunder
and i have my acoustic guitars are
tailors
made in el cajon california and my
electric guitars are
gibsons i have two gibson sgs
favorite song any black sabbath i had
bands growing up
so when i was a kid but i didn't play
guitar in my bands because i wasn't
skilled enough
and i played bass i'm not saying bass is
an easy skill
but you can learn how to play bass
pretty quickly
so i i got relegated to the bass
quite a bit and i also sang vocals but
and i had a and we were always in some
kind of hardcore band when i was a kid
so we had we were constantly playing and
we recorded like
17 songs and then we just had this demo
tape
which is what you did back in the day
you just made like demo tapes
and then you made well we made t-shirts
we made more t-shirts than we made songs
and the the best one which we brought
back from the dead
was the was the bronson's children that
was kind of the most epic name for the
band bronson children
it's a picture of charles bronson's head
and then in
like little toddler writing underneath
it says bronson's children
yeah yeah so this is about face
and i have something like 15 or 20
copies of about face the book by colonel
david hackworth but this
particular copy right here in plastic
this is this is what's called
an advanced reader's copy and so before
a book comes out
the book they release
a number of them and they send them to
the press or they send them to
reviewers or publishing companies or
whatever
so they're very rare because they
probably print like a hundred of them
maybe maybe maybe not even a hundred
so and then people review that book and
then they edit it down and then they
publish
the real book and so
i was at an event and a guy walked up to
me and he said
hey i have something for you and he gave
me this and i immediately knew what it
was because i'd never seen this version
before that looked like this so i
immediately knew
it must be an advanced reader copy and
sure enough
this is a limited edition special
advanced readers copy not for resale
uncorrected proof and not only
so this is this is as rare as you could
possibly get
for a version of this book and on top of
all of that
what's really amazing is it is actually
signed by
david hackworth who died in 2005 so
pretty amazing and definitely something
that i
keep in a well protected place
because i'm i'm really uh this book
meant a lot to me and and gave me a lot
of great information
what else surfboards yeah i i love the
surf
and so i have a i have a lot of
surfboards
probably yeah somewhere around 40
and they're all you know when when my
wife says to me oh you should get rid of
some of them
they're not the kind of boards that you
can just say oh i'm going to get rid of
i got a whole bunch that i
inherited from my buddy seth when he
died
he already had these incredible boards
and the fact that that he died and then
i got all those boards means that
they're not going anywhere well first of
all there's no such thing as a normal
day
you know when surfing the waves are
always different and so that's why you
have to have a nice quiver
and i have a nice quiver where i can
select the right tool for the job
the waves have been really good lately
and i've ridden a different board almost
every day which is kind of crazy
so um i don't i just just have a bunch
of
i'm really lucky to have some awesome
boards gene cooper
i got a skip fry i got a john holly
got a josh hall a lot of them are are by
gene cooper
a lot of them seth and i were pretty
into uh
gene cooper boards so i got this metal
water bottle i had to modify it a little
bit here
put some 550 cord in the zip tie i'm a
creature of habit
and so before i had this water bottle
which my wife got for me
because i think she was sick of me what
what i used to use for a water bottle
which was an old gatorade bottle that i
recycled and just used over and over
again for more than 10 years
i know it's i well that's what
apparently my wife thought it was gross
too
so but my wife got me this and now
i have this water bottle and i've had
this for i don't know i don't know how
long i've had it but it's been
definitely quite a while and yeah i
you know i use i i use this
for working out and then as you as you
know
when i'm eating like dinner i have this
lunch i have this
going on a walk or whatever going on a
hike i have this so i use this all the
time so
good water bottle good thing to have
well these are some oakley sunglasses
and uh
you know when i got into the navy when i
got into the dames back in the day
the only glasses pretty much that you
wore was oglies and
they were oakley blades back then which
are
straight not straight 80s late 80s early
90s was that was kind of the deal
and i don't you know i don't like the
bright light
when it's sunny out so i always have
sunglasses with me
you use them for shooting and you use
them for
just wearing around and and then and
then yeah so there's this
uh i forget what you i think you just
called it a string what do they call
what they call these strings
these these strings on your glasses are
were not
authorized in the military in the teams
we kind of got away with it right we're
having these things but kind of also not
some some of the old school guys be like
hey you can't have those but one of my
chiefs once said having glasses without
a strap on them is like having a watch
without a watch band
he goes what's up oakley was kind of
radical
with the what they did and so they made
these kind of like like radical
uh almost look like bugs eyes i was
probably one of
three people in the entire world that
actually bought these and wore them
so what's funny is when i when i was
when i when i just got out of the navy
i didn't want to spend money on oakley's
and i took a bunch of pictures with me
of me with oakley's over the years and i
put it into a into a little
powerpoint brief or something and i sent
it to oakley with hopes that they'd say
oh yeah
we'll hook you up and so i sent him this
cool picture
and there's like the the mountains in
one side and the ocean and the sun and
the other one and
i sent him a bunch of pictures with me
oakley's on on deployment
on patrol just the kind of things to
show
hey i've you know i've been representing
with the oakleys
i would always have them like here you
know there's the string around my neck
but i always have my oakley's with me
heartless response nothing i got nothing
from him which is a bummer
yeah uh the the classic floppy hat and
actually i still have the original
floppy hat that i got issued when i got
the seal team one and this is sort of
you know if you've ever heard you talk
about the fact that we're going to nom
in 1991 i thought i was going to nom
having a floppy hat
you know you kind of felt like you were
going to mom and i still have my this
one's obviously desert which i gotta
shoot later
but i still have the original one i
should have given it to you but uh yeah
you know you're always representing
that floppy hat thinking you're cool
flip-flops
they're not the best shoes for pursuit
or for running after
like an emergency scenario but
when you live in socal it sort of is
just i don't know i wear flip-flops all
the time and i think it has a lot to do
with jiu-jitsu because when you do
jujitsu you get on the mat
you know you got your flip-flops on you
take them off obviously if i'm going
somewhere where i know that the scenario
could unfold
hey you don't know what kind of scenario
i can handle pat mack is sternly against
flip-flops because he's written
action pap mac can you cut me a slack on
the flip flops please
bro well you got to be able to cut your
hair so yeah the at-home clipper set
for those people that are wondering uh
it's a wall clipper set
this is my second one that i've had in
about 30 years my first set of walls
lasted me like
25 years 0.5 on the sides 1.5 on top
that's the haircut
it's so liberating when you can cut your
own hair you don't have to worry about
going to a barber and waiting in line
and paying
like these things cost 40 bucks or
something that's one haircut
i probably give thousands of my own
haircuts so yeah no factor
all right my wife my wife helen
she's been hanging out with me she's
she's been hanging out with me for a
long time and it i was i'm not the
easiest person to
hang out with and she
has just been
awesome and you know i did a bunch of
deployments when she was
raising you kids and doing all that
stuff and
she was visiting my wounded guys in the
hospital and going to funerals and
she did all that and still kept taking
care of
you all and raising a bunch of kids so
uh i owe her big time i was on a ship at
the time on a ship board deployment with
a seal platoon
and we barely got off the ship on that
whole deployment
and we finally were going to
a place called bahrain and we didn't
really know what bahrain was
back this is
it was kind of uh it was kind of like
the las vegas at the time it was like
the las vegas of the middle east and
there was bars
and restaurants and it was kind of a
little bit crazy
they had like beer for us when we landed
like you guys so anyways we loaded up we
went out
and that's where i met that's where i
met your mom
the first thing i said to him well it
wasn't a jim carrey line
you know on a ship as a seal and there
was no internet on the
ship so every day we would just work out
work out work out watch
movies play spades work out watch more
movies and you only we only had a
certain number of movies because they
were on vhs cassette tapes do you know
what that is
so they were on vhs cassette tapes so
one of the movies that we were watching
at that time
was ace venture a pet detective and so
i walked up to her and i said
should i just call you aphrodite's
goddess of love
and of course she thought i was an idiot
and the rest is history
so there you go ten things
what did i say ten things that i utilize
on a regular basis and i guess my wife
falls into a category of
maybe i can't live without her all right
well there you go
at my daughter's request things that i
utilize on a regular basis
let her know if you you know
want to see some other weird video
that's more modern than what echo
charles thinks of
out